WEDNESDAY MORNING WHICH MEANS
IT'S TIME FOR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
CLIMATE CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION WE ARE IN. A
NEW ROOM. TODAY AND- OPTIMISTIC
THAT- ALL OF OUR SOUND ISSUES OF
MAGICALLY GONE AWAY BECAUSE OF
THE MOVE. SO TODAY WE ARE HAVING
AN IN PERSON HEARING IN THE
SWING SPACE THIS IS ROOM ELEVEN
HUNDRED. WE'LL BE TAKING SOME
TIME TO ADJUST BEING HERE I'M
SURE THE ROOM IS CAVERNOUS.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE. WE HAVE DOZEN PEOPLE
HERE RIGHT NOW. THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE PANELISTS THAT ARE LISTED IN
THE AGENDA WILL BE APPEARING-
REMOTELY AND IN PERSON TODAY WE
GET A LITTLE BIT OF EACH BUT-
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON MAY DO SO WHEN WE OPENED
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. AFTER THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM HAVE SPOKEN WE
WILL ALLOW PHONE TESTIMONY. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND-
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CALL IN TO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO. ONE
ONE ZERO ZERO THAT'S ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO ZERO. IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099. EXCUSE ME AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
ALL COMMENTERS WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK WE WILL NOT
BE TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY AND WE
HAVE ONLY ONE ITEM UP FOR
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING THAT'S
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. FIRST WILL AT ALL THE
PANELISTS GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY
AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND
AFTER THE DISCUSSION ITEMS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY CHOOSE TO
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS.
AND OF COURSE WILL END AS I
MENTIONED WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO BEFORE WE START WITH THE
UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE DTS THE REFORMS I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE YEARS OF WORK THAT
HAVE BEEN PERFORMED BY THE SUB
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA.
THE T. S. C. INDUSTRY AND THE
COMMUNITY LEADERS WHO GOT US
WHERE WE ARE TODAY THIS TRULY
HAS BEEN A COLLABORATIVE FOR A
GROUP EFFORT. DTS C. PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN THE GENERATION
USE AND DISPOSAL OF TOXIC
MATERIALS BUT FOR TOO MANY YEARS
THE T. S. C. DID NOT HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE OF STAKEHOLDERS. TO
BE AN EFFECTIVE REGULATOR. THE
ADOPTION OF A POLICY AND FEE
REFORM PACKAGE LAST YEAR WAS A
SIGNIFICANT TURNING POINT AND I
HOPE THAT THIS YEAR'S BCPS MARC
A GIANT STEP. TOWARDS A MORE
TRANSPARENT ACCOUNTABLE AND
EFFECTIVE T. T. S. C. THE BEAT
BCPS REPRESENT OVER A 25%
INCREASE IN DTS THE STAFFING
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT BRANCHES
AND PROGRAMS. WHICH IS AREFLECTION OF HOW THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDER
RESOURCE FOR MANY YEARS. BUT
THESE PROPOSALS WILL NOT BE THE
END OF OUR WORK THE SUBCOMMITTEE
INTENDS TO CONTINUE ITS
OVERSIGHT WORK TO ENSURE THAT
THE SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN
STAFFING RESOURCES RESULT IN
TANGIBLE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S FUNCTIONS.
INCLUDING MORE FREQUENT
INSPECTIONS MORE TIMELY
PERMITTING MORE CLEANUPS AND
MORE PRODUCT REVIEWS. THE LET'S
BEGIN NOW WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS WERE PLEASED
TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY. IF YOU
COULD GIVE US A SUMMARY OF THE
PROPOSALS BEFORE US. THE MORNING
CARE BLOOM GOOD MORNING BUT JUST
TO CONFIRM MY AUDIO. YEP I CAN
HEAR YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU THEN IT APPEARS ALL IS
WELL AND EVERYTHING IS WORKING.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU TO YOU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BENNETT
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON REBUS
AND SMITH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TOSPEAK TODAY. THE ITEMS IN OUR
BUDGET ARE INDICATIVE OF OUR
CONTINUED FOCUS ON PROTECTING
THOSE COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THEY CARRIED A HEAVY
ENVIRONMENTAL BURDEN AND ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
POLLUTION. AS YOU WELL
SUMMARIZED LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED KEY
GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL REFORMS TO
IMPROVE DGSE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FISCAL
STABILITY ALL IN SERVICE OF
HAVING A MORE EFFECTIVE DGSE
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE. WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE COOPERATIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE DEVELOPED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT
THOSE REFORMS IN PLACE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
COOPERATION AS WE IMPLEMENT THE
REFORMS. ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENTS OF THE FISCAL REFORM
PACKAGE WAS THE RESTRUCTURIN
AND RESETTING OF THE FEES THAT
SUPPORT THE GSES WORK. AS A
REMINDER IN THIS IN SUPPORT OF
THE REFORM WE COMPLETED AN
ANALYSIS OF THE WORKLOAD IN THE
DEEP IN THE DEPARTMENTS THREE
PRIMARY PROGRAMS. THE ANALYSIS
REVEALED AS YOU STATED THAT WE
LACKED ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MEET OUR
MISSION. THE FEE RATES
ESTABLISHED IN OUT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDED FOR THE
FIRST TIME SUSTAINABLE REVENUE
FOR DGSE WHILE SUPPORTING%
INCREASES IN OUR SERVICES. THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WILL BUILD ON THAT
FOUNDATION. THAT WAS PROVIDED BY
FILLING CRITICAL GAPS IDENTIFIED
IN THOSE WORKLOAD ANALYSES. THE
ANALYSIS IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
PRIORITY MANDATES AND ACTIVITIES
THAT WERE EITHER UNDERFUNDED FOR
ENTIRELY UNFUNDED. THE REFORM
PACKAGE SET UP SET FEE RATES TO
GENERATE AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO BEGIN TO
PAY FOR INCREASED LEVELS OF
SERVICE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE PACKAGING BCG'S WHICH WHICH
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA
NET GREEK WILL DESCRIBE IN
GREATER DETAIL IN A MOMENT HE'S
CONSISTENT WITH LAST YEAR'S
REFORM DISCUSSIONS. THE BCPS
BILLS APPROVED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET AS
WELL AS THOSE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE JAN TEN BUDGET. DOCUMENT
HOW DTS HE PLANS TO SPEND THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE GENERATED
FROM IN KEEP CREASED RATES. THIS
ADDITIONAL REVENUE IS A DOWN
PAYMENT ON BETTER PROTECTIONS
FOR CALIFORNIANS. OF THE FIFTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS A TOTAL OF
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL COUNT AND TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNTS.
WERE APPROPRIATED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM H. W. C. A. AND
THIRTY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FROM TWO TOSCO ARE
PROPOSED FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WILL BE USED BY DGSE TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL PROGRAM NEEDS INCLUDING
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR THE NEW
BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY.
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
ACTIVITIES. IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE VIOLATION SCORING PROCEDURE
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
INCREASES TO BE TNCS CRITICAL
LEGAL I. T. AND OTHER SUPPORT
PROGRAM RESOURCES THESE SORT
WITH THESE SERVICES ARE VITAL
FOR A SUCCESSFUL THE GSE REFORM
. PERMANENT FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OTHER IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES
INITIALLY FUNDED FROM THE
GENERAL FUND LAST YEAR INCLUDING
OUR CLEAN UP IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE AND
DEVELOPMENT OF A MODERNIZED
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN
. FOR EACH OF THESE INITIATIVES
DGSE WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
ITS PROGRESS TOWARD GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WE ARE EXPANDING ON THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS TIED TO OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN ON OUR DEVELOPING
DASHBOARDS AND METRICS THAT WE
TRACK OUR PROGRESS ON THESE
INITIATIVES. WE ARE COMMITTING
TO SHARING THOSE WITH YOU AND
OUR OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY SO
THAT YOU CAN MONITOR OUR MONITOR
THE PROGRESS WE ARE MAKING ON
THESE INITIATIVES. THIS FUNDING
ALLOWS US TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO WHOM WE ARE
ACCOUNTABLE. WE CAL ON
CONTINUING KERR ARE PRINTED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO PURSUE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. I ALSO
WANT TO UPDATE YOU ON SOME OF
OUR EFFORTS SINCE THE REFORM
PACKAGE WAS ENACTED. I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT ALL FIVE BOARD
MEMBERS ALL FIVE MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OUR MENTAL SAFETY HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED. AND THE NEW
MEMBERS ARE CURRENTLY ON
BOARDING AND THEY'RE RECRUITING
FOR THEIR EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND
OTHER STAFF. THEIR FIRST MEETING
IS ALREADY SCHEDULED FOR MARCH
THIRTY. WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE APPOINTEES
RECEIVING THEIR VALUABLE INPUT
AND COLLABORATING SO THAT THE
BOARD IN THE TNC CAN STRENGTHEN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
REPORT THE DGSE IS MAKING
TREMENDOUS STRIDES IN
IMPLEMENTING THE FIRST
INSTALLMENT OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. PROVIDED TOWARD
THE FRIDAY PROVIDING FOR THE
CLEAN UP IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE OR AS WE
CALL IT C. VCI. AND THAT
INCLUDES SEVERAL EFFORTS FIRST
THERE IS THERE ARE THE GRANT
PROGRAM. THAT WE CALL THE
EQUITABLE COMMUNITY
REVITALIZATION GRANT PROGRAM.
THE GRANT GUIDELINES AND
ELEMENTS OF THE PROGRAM HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED AND WE'VE
CONDUCTED OF OUTREACH WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE LEGISLATURE. TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES AND PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INTERVENTION
ENTITIES AND IN TOTAL WE'VE
SPOKEN TO MORE THAN A THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WE SOLICITED PRE
APPLICATIONS THE RESPONSE TO
THAT PRE APPLICATION PROCESS WAS
OVERWHELMINGLY POSITIVE WE HAD A
TOTAL OF EIGHTY EIGHT PRE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVE AND
THAT TOTAL OF A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
REQUESTS. FOR GRANT APPLICATIONS
ARE NOW BEING SUBMITTED THROUGH
AN OFFICIAL ONLINE GRANT
APPLICATION SYSTEM. THE GRANT
APPLICATION PERIOD CLOSES ON
APRIL FOURTH. SECOND THE SITE
DISCOVERY AND INVESTIGATION
PROGRAM HAS SCREENED MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED SITES IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND IS WORKING TO
FINALIZE CONTRACTS TO BEGIN
INVESTIGATIONS. THIRD WORKING
WORK ON THE TWENTY ONE HIGH
PRIORITY ORPHAN SITES IDENTIFIED
. LAST YEAR IS PROCEEDING WE CAN
PROVIDE MORE DETAIL ON THOSE
SITES IF YOU WOULD LIKE. LASTLY
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
WORK BEING DONE TO UPDATE THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN
. THE PLAN HAS BEEN FULLY
STAFFED AND THE NEW STUFF IS
DEVELOPING A WORK PLAN FOR
COMPILING THE REPORT AND
ULTIMATELY THE PLAN. D. GET
INITIAL DATA AND ADDITIONAL DATA
RESEARCH IS UNDERWAY. BUT
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO RE
ENVISION HOW WE TACKLE HAZARDOUS
WASTE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
GENERATION AND DISPOSAL OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE PRESENTS AN
EQUITY ISSUE FOR COMMUNITIES
WHERE HAZARDOUS WASTES ARE
GENERATED AND FACILITIES ARE
OPERATING. THE PLAN WILL PROVIDE
A ROAD MAP FOR REDUCING PERSONAL
SOCIETAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS FROM HAZARDOUS WASTE.
COMPLETION OF THE REQUIRED
INTERIM REPORT IS EXPECTED IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. TO BE
PRESENTED TO THE BOARD BASED ON
FEEDBACK FROM THE BOARD AND
FURTHER DIRECTION FROM THE BOARD
THE COMPLETION OF THE PLAN THE
OVERALL PLAN IS ANTICIPATED FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AS
YOU MENTIONED- WE HOPE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR IT TO
PROVIDE YOU REGULAR UPDATES
THROUGH THE OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
AND I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA
NEKI TO DESCRIBE OUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE REFORM
BCPS IN MORE DETAIL. FRANCESCA.
FIVE WAYS CONTROL ACCOUNT. AND.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW BUT WE
MISSED THE FIRST PART OF YOUR
PRESENTATION THE CASF DOES START
OVER THE OF THE GREAT. WELL THE
WELL I STARTED OUT BY THANKING
YOU SO MUCH- MEMBERS CAN'T MISS
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY- AS
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR WILLIAMS THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDES TWELVE DTS THE REFORM
BCPS TOTALING FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS UTILIZING THE INCREASED
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
AND TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT FUNDING PROVIDED BY FEW
REFORM. THIS AMOUNT WAS BASED ON
ANALYSIS DR WILLIAMS MENTIONED-
THAT WAS CONDUCTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO DETERMINE GAPS
BETWEEN OUR EXISTING BUDGET AND
THE FUNDING LEVELS NECESSARY TO
FULFILL OUR MISSION TO PROTECT.
CALIFORNIANS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
FROM EXPOSURE TO HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS. I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
A FEW OF THESE PROPOSALS AND
WHAT WE EXPECT TO ACHIEVE. FIRST
WE'VE PROPOSED TO TWELVE POINT
NINE MILLION SEVENTY THREE
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE CLEAN
UP IN VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
INITIATIVE WE REFER TO THAT AS
THE V. CI. THESE POSITIONS WILL
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM EFFORTS
FUNDED BY THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED FOR THE
INITIATIVE ENSURING WERE ABLE TO
DELIVER ON CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
TO CLEAN UP CONTAMINATED LAND IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THIS
INCLUDES OVERSIGHT OF CONTRACTS
TO CLEAN UP THE TWENTY ONE
PRIORITY ORPHAN SITES DR
WILLIAMS REFERENCED AND THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED TO HAVE A HIGH
POTENTIAL TO RELEASE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. THESE RESOURCES WILL
ALSO BE USED TO ADMINISTER MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED EQUITABLE
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION GRANTS
TO INCENTIVIZE COME. AND
INVESTMENT IN ADVANTAGE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND OVERSEE THE INSTIGATION
DISCOVERY AND FOR CLEANUP OF
CONTAMINATION CAUSED BY HUNDREDS
OF DRY CLEANERS AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. SECOND WE PROPOSED SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION AND THIRTY
SEVEN POSITIONS TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM. THE INCREASE
WILL ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENT ALL
FOUR PHASES OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS AND INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF PRODUCTS THAT CAN GO THROUGH
THE EVALUATION EVALUATIVE
PROCESS AND BRING SAFER
ALTERNATIVES TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. WE EXPECT TO IDENTIFY
FIVE NEW PRIORITY PRODUCTS AND
REACH AT LEAST SEVEN REGULATORY
RESPONSES ANNUALLY WITHIN A
COUPLE OF YEARS. DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING THE PACE AT WHICH
WERE ABLE TO REDUCE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS EXPOSURE TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS. THIRD WE ARE
PROPOSING A NUMBER OF CHANGES TO
FORTIFY OUR HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM STRENGTHEN
OUR ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS AND
OVERSEE THE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
MANAGEMENT OF HAZARDOUS WASTES.
ARE BUDGET INCLUDES TWO POINT
THREE MILLION FOR CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ONE POINT THREE
MILLION TO INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF TRANSPORTER
INSPECTIONS AND TWO POINT NINE
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED
QUALITY OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
GENERATOR INSPECTIONS FIRE
COOPER PARTNERS. AMONG OTHER
OUTCOMES WE EXPECT TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF TRANSPORT INSPECTIONS
BRING DOZENS OF ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AGAINST
TRANSPORTERS AND GENERATORS WHO
VIOLATE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS AND REFER
ROUGHLY FIFTY ADDITIONAL CASES
ANNUALLY TO PROSECUTION BECAUSE
OF THE ADDITIONAL CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES REQUESTED
. THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF THESE
RESOURCES IS TO INCREASE
COMPLIANCE RATES AND DECREASE
VIOLATIONS WHICH IN TURN
INCREASES PROTECTIONS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT
PARTICULARLY IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR MANY OF THESE
VIOLATIONS OCCUR. FOURTH WE ARE
REQUESTING RESOURCES TO FORTIFY
OUR OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY WITH THE PROPOSAL OF ONE
POINT THREE MILLION AND NINE
POSITIONS. THIS OFFICE
COORDINATOR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE WE'RE
WORKING EFFECTIVELY WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE BUDGET REQUEST
REFLECTS OUR COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING THAT WE IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
ALL PROGRAMS AND WITH THESE
RESOURCES WE EXPECT TO HOLD MORE
THAN THIRTY ADDITIONAL. PUBLIC
MEETINGS EACH YEAR AND REACH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THROUGH OUR VARIOUS OUTREACH
EFFORTS. YES WE ARE PROPOSING A
TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR EIGHTY FIVE
POSITIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
SUPPORTING EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CBC I AND THE
OTHER REFORM EFFORTS. THIS
INCLUDES PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR OUR LEGAL OFFICE
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL IN SUPPORTING
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS REGULATORY
AND CLEAN UP EFFORTS INCLUDING
RECOVERY AFFRONT FUNDS FROM
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. THIS
FUNDING WILL ALSO SUPPORT OTHER
FUNCTIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMISTRY LAB
WHICH PLAYS AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
OUR FORCING ACTIVITIES AS WELL
AS OUR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
HUMAN RESOURCES FISCAL SYSTEM.
AMONG OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CRUCIAL TO SUPPORT THE STAFF AND
ACTIVITIES PROPOSED IN OTHER
REFORM BCPS. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
PROPOSALS WERE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. ZELLERS A
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRANK MENACE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M AS YOU RECALL LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDED A
PHYSICAL IN GOVERNANCE I'M
REFORM PACKAGE FOR DTS THEME
THIS INCLUDED RESTRUCTURING THE
FEES THAT SUPPORTED APARTMENTS
TWO MAJOR SPECIAL FUNDS AND
ESTABLISHING THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AM THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES FROM THE
PHYSICAL FORM WOULD SOLVE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS IN THE
DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE YOUR SPECIAL
FUNDS. AND WITH SUPPORT
PROGRAMMATIC EXPANSIONS IN HIGH
PRIORITY AREAS. THE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION BCPS BEING HEARD
TODAY WHICH THERE IS A TABLE OF
AN AND YOUR AGENDA. ARE
REQUESTING THE AUTHORITY TO
SPEND THE ADDITIONAL REVENUES
ABOVE THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMMATIC GINS.
I'M BRING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE WITHIN
EXPENDITURE EXPENDITURE PLAN. ON
THE PROGRAMMATIC EXPANSIONS IT
WOULD PROPOSE IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. OVERALL WE FIND
THAT THE PACKAGE OF REFORM
IMPROVEMENT IMPLANTATION PCPS
ALIGNED WITH THE EXPENDITURE
PLAN PROVIDED LAST YEAR.
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THESE BCPS
- WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE USE- FUTURE BUDGET
HEARINGS TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT OF
HOW THE- DEPARTMENT IS
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAMMATIC
EXPANSIONS TO ENSURE THAT PTSD
IS MEETING ITS MISSION AND
ACHIEVING ITS LEGISLATIVE GOALS
. WE ALSO NOTE THAT- LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDED TOLD A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT- BROWNFIELD CLEANUPS.
THIS FUNDING LARGELY SUPPORTS
THEY CLEAN UPS- AND
INVESTIGATIONS AND A NEW LOCAL
GRANT PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS-
LOCAL INVESTIGATIONS CLEAN UPS
AND COMMUNITY WIDE ASSESSMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S- REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION BCPS INCLUDE
ONGOING FUNDING TO HIRE THE
STAFF NEEDED ADMINISTERED
ACTIVITY SUPPORTED BY THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. THIS IS ABOUT-
SEVENTY FOUR POSITIONS AND
THIRTY NINE MILLION OR THIRTEEN
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR- WE
KNOW NINE ALEX IS THAT WHILE THE
WORKLOAD FOR THE PROPOSED
STAFFING LEVELS IT'S CLEAR IN
THE NEAR TERM. THE NEED FOR
THESE POSITIONS WILL DIMINISH IN
FUTURE YEARS AS A DEPARTMENT
COMPLETES PROJECTS SUPPORTED BY
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- THAT'S
WHY I RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REVISIT DEPARTMENT STAFFING
LEVELS- IN FUTURE YEARS TO
EVALUATE. WHETHER THAT PROVES
LEVEL THE POSITIONS ARE STILL
NEEDED THE TRACK OUTCOMES OF THE
BROWNFIELDS FUNDING- BASED ON
THE LEGISLATURE TO ASSESSMENT OF
THE OUTCOMES AND WHETHER IT
FINDS MERIT IN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR STATE
CLEANUPS AND LOCAL GRANTS. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
SEVERAL OPTIONS IN THE FUTURE-
AS THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- SO
START TO BECOME I'M FULLY
EXPENDED. IS INCLUDE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES AND ADJUSTING
STAFFING LEVELS ACCORDINGLY.
REALLOCATING SOME OF THE-
STAFFING THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION BCPS TO INSTEAD
TO BE USED FOR THEY CLEANUPS ARE
LOCAL GRANTS THAT IS THE
STANDARD CONTINUED BUT DOWNSIZED
PROGRAM. ARGUS READER
REDIRECTING FUNDING AND STAFF
FROM THE BROWNFIELD CLEANUPS-
TWO DIFFERENT PRIORITY ACTIVITY
DETERMINED BY THE LARGEST. I'M
WITH HAVE TO TAKE ANY. THANK YOU
MISTER JIMENEZ DO WE HAVE ANY-
REPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I REMEMBER SIR JACK ARE
PART OF FINANCE- JUST YOU KNOW
BRIEFLY JUST TO REITERATE THAT
WOULD BE FAVORABLE TO ARE
DIRECTLY ALIGNED WITH LAST
YEAR'S IF THE RIVER OR- PACKAGE
AND THE COOK YOUR DISCUSSION
THAT WERE ENACTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I KNOW YOU CAN
COMMENT- BUT HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
LET ME BEGIN WITH A- BY ASKING
GOD DIRECTOR WILLIAMS- IF YOU
COULD DELVE A LITTLE BIT INTO
THE TOPIC OF ORPHANED SITES- YOU
MENTIONED IT BRIEFLY AND- THEN
IF WE WANTED MORE INFORMATION
ASK SO. THERE YOU GO. OKAY SO
I'LL TALK ABOUT THOSE THE TWENTY
ONE OR CONCERNS THAT WE
IDENTIFIED WE WENT THROUGH A
PROCESS OF- LOOKING AT
INDUSTRIES THAT WE KNEW WERE
PROBLEMATIC THAT HAD CAUSED
PROBLEMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND MOST NOTABLY DRY CLEANERS
DRY CLEANERS HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT A GREAT
DEAL OF GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION SO WE IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF- DRY CLEANERS SITES
THAT WERE FROM SIDES AND THEN.
SCREAMED FURTHER BASED ON
CONSIDERATIONS LIKE CALLUM VIRUS
GREEN SCORES AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE IN AND CAN YOU KNOW
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
WHITTLED THAT NUMBER DOWN TO THE
TWENTY ONE SITES CLOSE SITES ARE
NOW IN DIFFERENT STAGES OF THE
PROCESS IN TERMS OF- IN TERMS
OF. MOVING FORWARD WITH
ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATION- SOME
OF THEM ARE CLOSER TO HOME QUOTE
UNQUOTE SHOVEL READY AND BEING
ABLE TO- INITIATE THE CLEAN UP
SO THEY'RE NOT ALL AT THE SAME
STAGE THERE AT VARIOUS STAGES WE
ARE TRACKING THAT- AND I BELIEVE
WE MAY HAVE A STAFF MEMBER ON
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
WORK AND ADDITIONAL DETAIL ABOUT
THAT IF YOU'D LIKE BUT THAT'S
THE PROCESS WE USED TO IDENTIFY
THOSE SITES. AND AGAIN WE'RE
MOVING FOR WITH THEM. THANK YOU
. ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THAT TOPIC. SEEING
NONE- ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM
ANYONE ON THE DYESS. I'M SEE NOT
LET ME JUST SAY I WOULD. AM I IN
MY LAST FEW MONTHS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO- I WILL BE
HERE TO PROVIDE THE OF FUTURE
OVERSIGHT BUT- I THINK OF THE
FUTURE FOR DTS SEE LOOKS A- VERY
BRIGHT I THINK WE'VE LEFT YOU
WITH WE WILL BE LEAVING YOU
WITH- SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
CARRY OUT YOUR MISSION. THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T HAD IN THE
PAST AND- OF TE FOLLOWING FROM
AFAR BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING GOOD THINGS FROM THE TSC
IN THE FUTURE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE EFFORTS-
DIRECTOR AND ALL THOSE WHO WORK
FOR YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS. IN THE UP
MAKING FOR A- SAY FOR LACK LESS
TOXIC. FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIANS.
IF I MAY UM JUST REITERATE OUR
APPRECIATE- OUR APPRECIATION WE
KNOW IT WAS A VERY LONG PROCESS
TO GET THIS DO YOU KNOW TO. TO
GET THIS REFORM AND YOU REMAIN
FOCUSED ON IT AND CONTINUE TO
BRING THAT AWARENESS TO THE
CHALLENGES THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CHALLENGES WE
FACED. YOU MENTIONED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA WHO PLAYED
A PIVOTAL ROLE. AND WE I JUST
WANT TO SAY WE SHARE YOUR
OPTIMISM. WE ARE LOOKING AT HOW
FAR WE'VE COME IT WHETHER THAT'S
IN OUR PERMITTING PROGRAM IT'S
MAKING PERMIT DECISIONS AND I'M
SO MUCH SO MUCH MORE TIMELY
FASHION IT USED TO WHICH- OR ARE
TAKING MORE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT POSTURES- ACROSS THE
BOARD I MEAN I'M PROUD OF THIS
DEPARTMENT AND- I. I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO NUMBER OF
PEOPLE HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
LOOKING TRACK OUR PROGRESS AND
SEE SEE WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO. PUSH
THANK YOU FOR A FOR A AND OF
COURSE WE VAMP LONG ENOUGH THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT WAS ABLE
TO COME UP WITH A QUESTION. MY
AND MY APOLOGIES I CAME IN LATE
TO THIS MAY HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
IN IN THE PRESENTATION AND- JUST
JUST TWO QUICK QUESTIONS. ONE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ASKING FOR- A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BROWNFIELD CLEANUP- AND- YOU'RE
ASKING FOR PERMANENT STAFFING.
BUT YOU'RE ASKING FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING A DO YOU HAVE A GAME
PLAN FOR FUNDING THAT STAFFING-
AFTER THE ONE TIME FUNDING- RUNS
OUT. FRENCH COULD YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO THAT. SURE ABSOLUTELY-
ALTHOUGH THE FUNDING CONTAINED
IN S. B. ONE FIFTY EIGHT IS
TEMPORARY AND- AND I JUST WANTED
TO. POINT OUT THAT THAT D. IT'S
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
FUNDING- THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WAS APPROPRIATED IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR IF I
GOT THAT RIGHT- ALTHOUGH THE
THIS FUNDING IS TEMPORARY THERE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A NEED TO
REMEDIATE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES ONCE THE FUNDING IS
EXHAUSTED WITH FOUR TO WORKING
WITH YOU. ON FUTURE
POSSIBILITIES WHEN THAT TIME
COMES THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
EVALUATE THE PROGRAMS FUNDED
THROUGH SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT
DETERMINE HOW BEST TO CONTINUE
TO REMEDIATE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
. THANK YOU CAN IF I IF I COULD
ADD A LITTLE BIT IN AB ONE OF
THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAD DURING
THE REFORM IS THERE ARE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND. UNMEDIATED
UNDERDRESSED- CONTAMINATED SITES
AROUND THE STATE SO WE KNOW THE
NEED IS LARGE. AND WE- THAT IS
ONE REASON WHY THE BOARD WAS
CHARGED WITH LOOKING AT THE
PRIORITIES FOR OUR CLEAN UP
WORK. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND SO
THE BOARD WILL TAKE AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN LOOKING AT THE CLEAN UP
PLANS- AND THINKING ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TO ADDRESS FUNDS
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO TACKLE
THAT- THAT. OBVIOUSLY HUGE NEED
. THANK YOU IN AND MY OTHER
QUESTION- AND AGAIN YOU MAY HAVE
ADDRESS IF YOU HAVE A 70%
VACANCY RATE ASKING FOR MORE
POSITIONS. WHAT S THE GAME PLAN
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO SOLVE YOUR
VACANCY PROBLEM. IT JUST
DEFINING THE FINALLY THE PEOPLE
. SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE THAT
ONE AS WELL AND MEREDITH CAN CAN
AT HER COMMENTS BUT WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC INITIATIVE TO EXPAND
AND DIVERSIFY OUR WORKFORCE AND-
IT DOES CONSIDER- CURRENT
VACANCIES AND ANTICIPATED
RETIREMENTS WE BEGAN RAMPING UP
OUR HIRING LAST FALL AND NOW WE
ARE AVERAGING MORE THAN THIRTY
FIVE HIRES A MONTH ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT COMPARED TO. FIFTEEN
HIRES A MONTH- PRIOR TO THIS
INITIATIVE- APPROXIMATELY 70% OF
THOSE HIRES ARE COMING FROM
OUTSIDE OF DGSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO REDUCE OUR VACANCY RATE- WE
ARE CONDUCTING WE CONDUCTED- A
FEW HIRING FAIRS AS WELL AS
INCREASED OUR OUTREACH AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
AND ORGANIZATIONS AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. THE
NEEDS OUTRAGE EFFORTS ARE HAVING
AN IMPACT IT'S INCREASING THE
QUALITY AND QUANTITY OF OUR
CANDIDATE POOLS AND- STARTING TO
CHIP AWAY AT A VACANCY RATE-
RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT A 13% WE
REDUCED IT FROM 15% SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE FISCAL YEAR AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
PRODUCE THAT THEY CAN SEE RATE
WITH THIS INITIATIVE. GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD LUCK WITH
THAT AND I SURE- CHAIRMAN
BLOOMS- COMMENTS THAT THE FUTURE
CAN BE BRIGHT NOW WITH TWO OF
ITS PROPER FUNDING AND I'VE WHAT
I HOPE WE CAN DO IS INFUSE A
REAL SENSE OF MISSION AND THE
PEOPLE OF THAT WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IT'S SOMETHING PEOPLE
CAN REALLY BE PROUD OF TO WORK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TERMS OF
PROTECTING. CALIFORNIANS THANK.
I WANT I CAN I CAN READ. AND
JUST SAY- IN A STORY THAT WAS
DONE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO OUR
STAFF RESPONDED. THAT THE WERE
VERY MUCH MOTIVATED BY OUR
MISSION THEY'RE VERY- THEY'RE
VERY ENGAGED AND FRANCESCA AND I
SEE EVERY DAY- THE COMMITMENT TO
THE MISSION IS TREMENDOUS AND IT
IS. IT'S OUR IT'S OUR IT'S OUR
SECRET WEAPON. IN TERMS OF- HOW
STRONG THE DEPARTMENT CAN BE.
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR- WILL TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. BLOOM HERE SENATE
FRIEDMAN MULLIN ANDERSON RIVAS
LET. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN- IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE- NOW WOULD BE A GOOD
TIME SO SEEING NONE OF. WE WILL
A CLOSE OUT THAT ITEM AND TO
MOVE ON TO- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT NON DISCUSSION
ITEMS ARE THERE ANY. SEEING NONE
ALL ADDICT A. R. COMMENT ON
ISSUE THIRTEEN I LIKE TO COMMENT
TO REACH CAL RECYCLE THAT GIVEN
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE BKK
LANDFILL WE SHOULD BE LOOKING TO
REASSESS THREATS TO OPERATING
AND CLOSED LANDFILLS. TO JUDGE
WHETHER OUR CURRENT CLOSURE AND
POST CLOSURE FINANCIAL
ASSURANCES ARE ENOUGH TO PROTECT
TAXPAYERS. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AS THERE ARE A FEW
LANDFILLS ON THE COAST THAT MAY
BE IMPACTED BY SEA LEVEL RISE
AND WHEN CANNELLA. ALMOST
VISUALIZE- THE CATASTROPHE OF
THAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A LANDFILL
WERE TO BECOME A INUNDATED BY- A
SEA WATER BUT THAT IS A FUTURE
THAT WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
UNFORTUNATELY. WE WILL NOW BEGIN
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT EVERYONE
WILL HAVE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. WE WILL
START WITH THOSE IN THE ROOM AND
THEN OPEN THE PHONE LINES. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE CALLING IN
THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE.
1-850-110-0185. ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO. AND DEAL WITH THAT IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM I KNOW
EVERYBODY IS HERE SO I THINK
THERE'S NO ONE HERE TO SPEAK ON
PUBLIC COMMENT WHO IS IN THE
ROOM. OPERATOR ARE YOU OUT THERE
AND READY TO CALL ON FOLKS WHO
ARE CALLING IN TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT. YES THANK YOU FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
THAT MANY ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
PARTICIPANT WE JUST HAVE THE
GIVEN THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT.
AND AGAIN AS A REMINDER. AS A
REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE'RE
GOING TO LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- I'M JADE
TOURNAMENT WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I'M CALLING
IN TODAY TO COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
NOT PRESENTED BUT RELATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION- SO WE ALONG WITH
SEVERAL ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
ARE. REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY SUPPORT FUND AT DPRK
THAT WOULD PROVIDE DIRECT
PROTECTIONS FROM AND PRE
PREVENTION MEASURES FOR
PESTICIDE DRIFT EXPOSURE AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS. EVEN AS
THE STATE MOVES TOWARD
SUSTAINABLE AND ECOLOGICAL PEST
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES AND
ACKNOWLEDGES THE HARM CAUSED BY
HAZARDOUS AND TOXIC PESTICIDES
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PRIMARILY LOT NEXT CONTINUE TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
STATUS QUO PESTICIDE USE. WE
BELIEVE THAT A COMMUNITY SUPPORT
FUND THAT'S PROTECTION SUCH AS
INDOOR AIR PURIFIERS BUFFER
ZONES AND OTHER STRATEGIES THAT
REDUCE EXPOSURE AND PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH- ARE CRUCIAL THAT
WE ENVISION THE FUND TO BE
DETERMINED BY A CLEAR COMMUNITY
DRIVEN PROCESS LED BY RESIDENTS
IN AREAS OF THE STATE MOST
IMPACTED BY HARMFUL PESTICIDES.
SUPPORT FROM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE DEPARTMENT TO INCLUDE A
DESCRIPTION CHAU ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN THE MAY REVISION.
OF THE BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU UP AND
MAKE SURE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME WELL IT'S A MARCH MIRACLE.
AND I DID NOTE- THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN- STUCK IN THE
DOORS JUST A MOMENT AGO DID YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS YOU WANT TO
MAKE ON ANY ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
RIGHT THANK YOU. I AM WELL THAT
BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION OF
THIS- VERY SHORT TO A BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE HEARING. WE WILL
BE BACK NEXT WEEK THAT RIGHT.
NEXT NEXT WEDNESDAY AND I'D BE
WILLING TO BET THE HEARING WILL
BE A LITTLE BIT LONGER AT THAT
TIME. THANK YOU ALL.